i have a follow-up to this question
no it's not it's much simpler um but
it's going to give us it's going to give
us a new concept okay so
read this with me it's a follow-up to
this
number that we got here um and i promise
actually it's like two lines are working
that's it not
nearly as involved as this what single
amount of money
if we invested it now just deposit it
into the bank account and then just let
it sit right
what single amount of money would
attract interest like if we put it in
and let it sit there for amount of time
to be equivalent to to this to the 100
installments over nine years that's
that's what this produces right that's
a9
okay so i'm interested in what if i
didn't do
installments over and over again what if
i just took like a big heap of money
popped in the bank and then walked away
after nine years
how much would i need to have put in to
still arrive
at this point okay so i'm kind of like
this is my answer now right
now this is where i'm going to return
actually i should use my different color
gonna return to not even right the idea
that you started with mistakenly which
is compound interest
right so i'm saying um and i'm going to
call it
x for now there's some value there's
some value
and i can just apply compound interest
to it
and i'm going to get to here right so if
i apply compound interest to just this
single amount
what does that look like what formula do
i have for this we've already referred
to it earlier today
yeah this is it's going to be a equals
a principle and i'm calling that x right
times
1 plus r which we've already seen is 1.1
to the power of n right and we can fill
this in everything except for the x
right what's the amount we want to end
on
yep that guy right there so let's pop
that in whoops i wrote my
numbers in the wrong hold off
all right okay that's that
okay same amount of time so x is the
unknown
i've got my 1.1 here and then there's
the uh there's the nine which is how
long this thing was going for
okay i promise this is going to be
simpler look i just have to do some
division here yeah the calculator is
going to do most of the heavy lifting
for me
i'm going to do this figure divided by
whatever i get out of that
component just calculation can you go to
your calculator and tell me what that is
let me use head scratching
where's the plus one
one plus r you tell me this part oh yeah
i've i've done it it's right there
one plus r is zero point one yeah that's
the
that's the interest rate and the
interest rate i'm sensing
has someone giving me a number at this
point please anyone
karen you got it uh 576.75
ooh i would different i did yeah i feel
like i got a different number
575.9 yeah
hmm
zero three yeah yeah is that okay i'm
trying to remember back to my earlier
working okay
so even though put your arm put your
pens and your calculators down for a
moment
even though that was a relatively simple
thing to do
we've actually introduced a whole new
idea the whole new idea is captured in
this question
but i want to provide some names under
this right
think about this pen's out of hands
right we have an installment a deposit
that happens regularly
okay and then if we cast our eyes into
the future
we get this figure here okay this figure
i want you to take that put a big box
around it
and i want you to give it a new name
because this is the value of our
investment or our superannuation or
whatever
in the future a value in the future we
call this guy
a future future value crazy right
i know they're very creative sometimes
okay now
you might have heard this phrase before
right future value now i want to compare
that
or contrast it rather to this guy this
is kind of like what this value is
has grown from but today right it's the
value
right now it's not in the future it's in
the presence so we call it present
value okay yep question where would you
57 nine to get to the one three five
seven
yes that is the question okay let me let
me try and show you this okay
um by the way that is see how i left
space for a heading that is the heading
present and future value and
yeah it's it's really important in
business it's all over
okay now you guys are going to do some
questions on the basis of this
but the most important thing i want to
get across to you today is
what i know this means like why does
this matter so i'm going to try and give
you a visual
okay what are you looking at each each
of these green dots
each of these green dots represents
everything that we have just written
on the board in your books right it's
installments money going in
and then interest calculations now it's
a bit difficult when you just see the
numbers
so what i'm going to try and do is show
you how it's growing um maybe this
makes a little more sense to you right
now remember every year at the end of
every year
there's an installment of 100 it kind of
happens instantly right so that's what
those vertical lines are and you can see
each vertical line it's the same chunk
every time because it's a hundred
dollars
every time does that that make sense yes
okay
but then you also have these sort of
intermediate parts right you've got this
line it starts off quite gentle but by
the end it's quite steep actually it's
increasing
that's not the installment what is that
that's the interest calculation right
and you should expect by the way
that towards the right hand side up here
the reason it gets
steeper because there's more stuff that
you're applying the 1.1
uh the 10 interest toward right so
that's why towards the end here
like if you have a look at that gap over
in the top right hand corner like it
jumps up
um very dramatically because 10 percent
of a large amount is a fairly large
amount
following so far okay now what i try to
think about
is that um that that last number uh one
three five seven
ninety five right that's what we're
calling future value
okay it's the height where you end up is
that okay like that's
visually what it represents okay now
before i then connect that to present
value i want you to
look back at where we worked out like we
brought out the formula do you remember
that because we're like
i don't have time for evaluating all
this my calculator
so we went to the sum of a gp do you
remember that now i want you to have a
look
over here on my left hand side i've
given you those equations right do you
recognize that equation
that's the sum of a gp you can see the a
and the r to the n minus one do you see
it all there okay so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to show you i'll take
away this um
all these lines here i'm going to show
you what that gives us right and i hope
it makes sense this is an exponential
curve right we're at the beginning of
the exponential curve so you don't quite
see the
crazy take off part but hopefully you
can see its gradient getting steeper and
stickier over time
right coming back to what we're looking
at in continuous random variables in
statistics right you remember how we
often have
discrete situations like things happen
one step at a time and we also
sort of model them with continuous
situations they're hugely valuable to us
right okay now how do we compare this to
present value this final number that we
have over here um present value is a
time
sorry it's a quantity of money that
happens now present right
so it isn't on the right hand side of
the graph this is as time progresses
where should present value be
present it's now that's going to be all
on the left-hand side right at the
beginning like these nine years have not
elapsed yet right
so the number of present value is is
this figure i i don't know why i got
something different there i think
something happened with my rounding but
we're in the right ballpark like 575
576 now what does it mean to take that
and then apply compound interest to it
well it's to take away that model right
there
it's applying that same idea without
adding any more of those steps
you see this is just letting it sit and
compound interest just does its thing
like a smooth curve
and you end up at the exact same point
okay
so two different ways to go about it we
can either
i'm gonna get rid of no i'll leave that
there we can either go in these steps
you can see by doing 100 every year how
many times by the way does he do this
100 aaron does it every year nine years
so it's nine times
so how much does he actually deposit
900 right as compared to
just depositing 575 if we did that it's
like it's
half right and if you do that and just
not
not touch it it will still grow that
same amount so this is talking about the
power
of compound interest okay